>> Sean: KELSEY HANDLER HAS
OFFICIALLY ENTERED THE REALM OF
UNHINGED.
THE LATE NIGHT HOST LAUNCHED
GRAHAM.
IT IS IT SO GRAPHIC WE'LL NOT
SHOW IT TO YOU ON THE PROGRAM.
IN CHELSA WORLD DECENCY IS ONLY
SHE TWEETED OUT A MEAN SPIRITED
PARODY OF SARAH SANDER AND HERE
EVERYONE HAS THE POWER TO CHANGE
THE CHANNEL.
BUT IF WE SAY SOMETHING THAT IS
DEEMED INAPPROPRIATE.
THEY WANT OUR HEAD-ON A CHIPPING
BLOCK AND BOYCOTT AND WHAT IS
YOUR REACTION?
>> WELL, WE HAVE TO POINT OUT
THE HYPOCRISY HANDLER CONTINUES
TO DISPLAY THE PATTERN.
I AM SICK OF THE HOLLYWOOD
LIBERALS WHO GO TO THE HOLLYWOOD
SHOWS AND ME TO TIMES IS UP FOR
EVERYONE AND TWEET CRAP LIKE
THIS THIS IS DISGUSTING AND VILE
AND YET WE ARE SUPPOSED TO VILE
THE CHARADE OF WONDERFUL MORAL
PEOPLE.
NO, NO.
>> Sean: YOU DEBATED HER.
AND LET'S REMIND PEOPLE ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED.
>> I DO BELIEVE THAT HE IS
A GOOD PRESIDENT AND DONE THING
AND PEOPLE TALK ABOUT HE TWEETED
IF HE'S HELPING PUT AMERICA
FIRST AND PUTTING US ON THE
WORLD STAGE AND ENFORCING.
I CAN DEAL WITH A MEAN TWEET.
>> BUT WHY, A MEAN REPRESENTS SO
LIKE A ANGRY AND HE LASHES OUT
AT PEOPLE AND VENGEFUL AND SAYS
NASTY THINGS.
>> Sean: SHE'S ACT BEING LIE
A TODDLER.
>> OF COURSE SHE IS.
FILM FESTIVAL AND THIS WOMAN
ALTHOUGH I HAD A DECENT
CONVERSATION WITH HER.
I DON'T KNOW IF SHE KNOWS WHAT
SHE IS DOING.
I THOUGHT SHE WAS AT LEAST SOME
BUT SHE'S LIKE THE REST OF THE
SEE- CALL WOULD COMEDIANS.
THEY INJECT POLITICS IN THE ACT
AND THEY ARE NOT FUNNY AND THEY
ARE DISGUSTING AND YET THEY GET
AWAY WITH IT BECAUSE THEY ARE ON
THE LEFT.
>> Sean: WHAT DID YOU THINK MUCH
HER PERSONALLY.
>> SHE WAS VERY KIND TO ME AND
RESPECTFUL.
AND WE HAD A GOOD CONVERSATION.
I CAN'T SAY THE SAME THING ABOUT
>> Sean: I DIDN'T KNOW YOU WERE
DOING THAT.
>> TREVOR NOAH AND BILL, AND
ALL.
LADIES OF THE VIEW, JOIN THE
TODAY AND TALKING TO THE
INTOLLANT LEFT AND I PUT MYSELF
IN THOSE SITUATIONS BECAUSE I
HOPE FOR A CONVERSATION.
I DID THAT WITH CHELSEA AND I
FIND WHOUT SHE DID DISGUSTING.